[Musique]
il y à un âge où on ne croit plus
vraiment au père noël
il n'empêche on a tous été bercé par des
comptes ou des histoires un petit peu
mystérieuse lors de notre enfance je ne
sais pas si vous vous souvenez d'un
conte particulier qui vous a marqué et
que vous auriez aimé transmettre que
vous avez transmis peut-être à vos
enfants ou à vos petits enfants
moi je me souviens de l'inde ou tout
particulièrement
je ne sais pas son auteur d'ailleurs je
n'avais pas demandé
j'avais une dizaine d'années peut-être
c'est l'histoire d'un prince oriental
très pris par les affaires de son
royaume et qui décide un jour de
convoquer ces sages ces savants il leur
dit mes amis écrivez moi un certain
nombre de volumes tous qu'il est
important de savoir de connaître à notre
époque et que je transmettrai il se met
à l'ouvragé quelques temps plus tard il
lui apporte 74 volume tout ce qu'il faut
savoir et tout ce que l'on peut
transmettre en sciences en technique en
art en philosophie en littérature une
encyclopédie très pris par les affaires
de son royaume il enrhumé la lecture à
plus tard ils les convoquent à nouveau
mes amis et le temps me manque pour lire
autant de livres est-ce que vous pouvez
les résumés en seize livres
il s'exécute là encore le temps passe
très pris par les affaires du royaume et
leur dis mes amis le temps me manque
pour lire autant de livres est ce que
vous pouvez les résumer en un seul
ouvrage ils le font mais le roi devenue
très vieux n'a plus le temps
séjour lui sont comptés il convoque à
nouveau les sages les philosophes les
savants il leur dit mes amis est ce que
vous pourriez résumé ce que je dois
savoir d'essentiel ex que je dois
transmettre en une phrase
et si possible en un mot les sages se
taisent
réfléchissent et 10
mais au fait le compte s'arrête là sur
une parole inexprimée sur une immense
frustration et se comptent inaboutie à
hanter les nuits et en fait on y
réfléchissant sage parmi les sages
si j'avais eu à transmettre un mot au
prince je crois que j'aurais dit non
j'ai pas voulu dire c'est un secret
d'ailleurs vous pourriez vous dis à ce
prince qui serait la fin le terme ultime
de l'existence
je vous laisse réfléchir je vous
reposera la question dans un quart
d'heure toujours est il que j'ai
toujours été fasciné par cette question
de la transmission
comment transmettre
pourquoi transmettre à qui transmettre
que transmettre et comme ce compte
renvoyer à une question essentielle
je suis devenu tout naturellement
professeur de philosophie attaché à
transmettre une culture un esprit
critique à former des hommes et des
femmes libres autant qu'il se peut
j'étais fasciné également par le mystère
des civilisations disparues comme vous
probablement l'egypte ancienne les mayas
encore vat l'île de pâques les
civilisations qui naissent qui se
développe qui meurent panne de la
transmission est l'interrogation était
précisément la suivante comment
retrouver l'élan de ces grands
mouvements de civilisation qui finissent
par façonner l'identité d'un peuple et
toute une culture
comment souffler sur la braise pour
allumer une petite flamme si frêle 6 et
6 hésitante si vacillante
sachant qu'avec une petite flamme on
peut toujours allumée de grands
incendies guide dans cette recherche par
quelques verres quelques mots un petit
peu comme suning ghosn cette musique de
la tradition juive s'émousse était par
exemple ceux du poète jean pierre
calloch pour être breton morts pendant
la guerre de 14
apprends moi les mots qui réveille un
peuple et j'irai messagers d'espérance
les redire à ma bretagne en de rui
apprendra les mots qui réveille d'un
peuple ou celui du poète patrice de la
tour du pin
les pays qui n'ont pas de légende sont
condamnés à mourir de froid alors je me
suis dit hé bien si je crée une île de
pâques une nouvelle île de pâques à
l'image d'une civilisation projet
ambitieux
sachant qu'il y ait en bretagne un
millier de st réputés tels qui ont donné
leur nom à la quasi totalité des
communes de bretagne
la carte d'état-major de la bretagne est
une véritable litanie des saints il faut
savoir qu'en bretagne nos ancêtres ne
sont pas les gaulois mais les gallois
ainsi que les cornouaillais ainsi que
les irlandais est qu'ils ont traversé la
manche il y a quinze siècles sur
d'improbables jauge de pierres dans le
cadre d'une merveilleuse odyssée celtic
se sont installés en armorique et le
récit de leur vie a finit par composer
agents d'air extraordinaire ces fameuses
vies de saints c'est aussi le récit de
la ville d'ys saint pol aurélien qui
était ce un dragon et ses récits que
l'on centre à ce que l'on se
transmettait le soir au coin du feu lors
des veillées au fil des générations a
finit par composer une culture populaire
sont les récits de fondation c'est
l'équivalent pour nous tous c'est de ce
qu'est la mythologie grecque
alors comment faire mémoire de cette
histoire mais tout simplement l'idée
s'est imposée avec la force tranquille
d'une évidence et si je faisais
effectivement un millier de statues à
l'effigié des saints bretons puisque je
vous le disais chaque commune bretonne
porte le nom d'un saint saint pol de
léon saint malo saint brieuc alors vous
êtes dit oui mais la liste est courte
non non non non dans chaque mot il y un
saint qui se cache
lorsque vous avez laon où la lance
l'abbaye le monastère lanildut tu le
monastère de cinq minutes landivisiau le
monastère de sainte et vizio les blue le
peuple de plounéventer le peuple de
scinder 21 ploumilliau le peuple de 5
millions et ainsi de suite
et donc voilà je vais faire une île de
pâques bretonne avec des statues géantes
de quatre à six mètres de haut
plus que l'île de pâques il y à peu près
890 moais l'île de pâques
on ne peut pas en faire moins de 1000 en
bretagne je soumets le projet à deux
cabinets d'études dont un nord américain
il est utile projet
la réponse est sans appel il faut
abandonner le projet un projet qui
repose sur le rappel d'une époque
mérovingienne c'est à dire l'époque de
dagobert de childebert mais vous n'y
pensez pas tout le monde a oublié cela
un projet qui repose sur des seins ou
sommes en pleine époque de
sécularisation de sortie de la religion
un proche un projet qui rappellera toute
une culture régionale culture bretonne
mais enfin nous sommes confrontés au
rouleau compresseur d'une sous culture
mondialisée
un projet qui prendra place en bretagne
en plein coeur de la bretagne dans une
région frappée par la désertification à
l'écart des routes touristiques
c'est irréaliste un projet qui sera
financé par le mécénat en plein
ralentissement économique
un projet qui ne comprendra pas d'entrée
payante mais vous êtes un doux rêveur
dois-je continuer la liste de toutes les
impossibilités qui rendait ce projet
impossible aujourd'hui dans une petite
commune du centre bretagne 114 statue
géante de quatre à six mètres de haut se
dresse pour composer ce que j'ai appelé
la vallée des saints me souvenant que
dans ma jeunesse j'avais descendu le nil
visité la vallée des rois et des reines
et méditait sur les civilisations
disparues au sommet de la grande
pyramide de khéops à 140 mètres de
hauteur et à la fin de cette année 2010
8 la vallée des saints qui est un lieu
de transmission d'une histoire bretonne
oublié qui est un lieu de transmission
d'un savoir faire artistique celui des
sculpteurs et on va ouvrir dans quelques
semaines la première école de sculpture
monumentale d'europe lieu de
transmission d'une culture populaire qui
n'était plus enseignée lieu de
transmission d'un esprit et bien cette
vallée des saints à la fin de l'année
2018 selon le rythme de fréquentation
actuelle va dépasser le nombre de quatre
cent trente mille visiteurs avec
l'objectif même si ce n'est pas une fin
en soi d'un million de visiteurs d'ici
quatre à cinq ans
[Musique]
je
cette aventure n'est pas un cas isolé
il y a près d'un quart de siècle je me
suis attaché à relancer un très vieux
pèlerinage
le tro breizh au tour de bretagne qui
invitait autrefois chaque breton à faire
une fois dans sa vie
le tour dès cette cathédrale anciennes
et actuelles de bretagne quimper saint
pol de léon tréguier saint brieuc saint
malo dol vannes soit 800 km environ un
mois de marche raison de 25 à 30
kilomètres par jour là aussi quand il
s'est agi de le relancer
personne n'y croyait ça n'était plus
l'époque aujourd'hui simplement ce qu'on
a fait c'est de mettre un vin nouveau
dans une autre très vieille c'est à dire
qu'on a simplement découper ce périple
de cathédrales en cathédrale à raison
d'une étape chaque année est aujourd'hui
bien le tro breizh en tant que marche
collective et la plus grande marche
collective sur une aussi longue période
c'est à dire sur une semaine en france
si je vous dis cela 5 c'est simplement
pour vous dire que là où il ya une
volonté il ya un chemin et c'est la
raison pour laquelle moi je souhaiterais
vous associer un projet qui sera
certainement l'une des aventures les
plus passionnantes du 21e siècle
lors cette aventure c'est ce que
j'appelle la cité de la paix alors je
vous disais tout à l'heure que j'étais
professeur de philosophie donc j'ai
commencé ma carrière
il ya déjà un certain temps c'était en
1976 l'autre millénaire coopérant au
nord cameroun sur les hauts plateaux de
l'adamaoua à 1200 mètres d'altitude en
plein pays musulmans jeune professeur
sans expérience
sans bibliothèque de travail sans
photocopieuse sans internet sans
télévision téléphone une fois par
semaine et le courrier et au rythme des
bouteilles à la mer mais des classes aux
cinquante élèves qui étudiaient le soir
à la lumière des réverbères là était la
vraie vie en même temps à former les
premiers équipages de la jeune histoire
du cameroun
et quand je suis retourné au cameroun il
ya quelques années en touriste cette
fois ci j'ai été bouleversée de voir
l'évolution du pays
il faut savoir que le cameroun c'est une
afrique en miniature il ya une centaine
d'ethnies une centaine de tribus et
chacune a ou avait un type
d'architecturé vernaculaire bien
spécifiques
lessard et les fulbé les kasubi des
mousses goom les cases des pygmées et
lorsque je suis revenu effectivement
tout cela avait disparu remplacées par
des maisons en briques et en tôles
pathétique caricature de la modernité
inadapté au climat il crève de chaud là
dessous conduisant à l'endettement
alors qu'autrefois les matériaux
naturels ne coûtait rien et créer des
solidarités de bâtisseur tout un
patrimoine architecture vernaculaire
était en train de disparaître
l'idée était donc de faire un
conservatoire de l'architecturé
traditionnelle camerounaise
pendant qu'il en est encore l'unesco
tire la sonnette d'alarmé
bientôt tout sera effacée je vais donc à
yaoundé la capitale du cameroun je
rencontre trois ministres un recteur
d'université plusieurs maires et je
récupère très vite 500 hectares pour
bâtir donc ce conservatoire de l'
architecture traditionnelle au nord
cameroun
mais entre temps vous suivez l'actualité
les incursions meurtrières de boko haram
en provenance du nigeria voisin rendre
ce projet momentanément impossible en
tout cas
être entre parenthèses et cette
parenthèse et bien j'ai décidé de la
mettre à profit en modifiant le projet
c'est-à-dire non plus simplement faisant
un conservatoire de l' architecture
traditionnelle camerounaise messin
conservatoire de l'architecturé
traditionnelle mondiale non plus un
projet breton mais un projet mondial
l'idée étant de rassembler tous les pays
du monde pour bâtir façon exposition
universelle mais dans une optique de
vocations pérenne les habitats les plus
emblématiques de l' architecture
vernaculaire en terre avec les maisons
terre peut durer plusieurs siècles si
elles sont bien entretenues en pierres
sèches ou en bois alors ce projet
c'est tout simplement un projet que l'on
doit conduire au nom d'une exigence tout
à fait légitime évidente de sauvegarde
d'un héritage universel au nom du droit
des peuples à la continuité historique
alors ce projet sera un vaste chantier
qui mettra sur un même site qui fera
bâtir sur un même endroit des jeunes et
des moins jeunes de tous les pays de
tous les continents avec des passerelles
qui s'ouvriront vers des chantiers d'éco
construction
afin de pallier à la fois un savoir
faire ancestral et puis les exigences
légitimes du confort et de la modernité
alors puisqu'il faut prouver le
mouvement en marchant on va commencer
dès l'an prochain ce premier chantier
qui consistera à bâtir les premières
cases au but du cameroun alors les cases
au but ce sont des cases de 15 à 16
mètres de haut
celles qui ont fasciné andré gide
lorsqu'il était de passage dans cette
région d'afrique centrale et qu'il est
décrit d'ailleurs dans ses carnets le
retour du tchad
il n'en n'existe quasiment plus ce
projet portera le nom de cité de la paix
pour faire un mémoire des hommes et
femmes de paix de ces différents pays
par exemple pour les cases au but du
cameroun est bien la promotion de
bâtisseur sera placée sous le patronage
de monseigneur yves plumey évêques
bretons originaire de vannes que j'ai
bien connue assassiné étranglé un petit
matin chez lui au nord cameroun pour des
maisons d'inde ça pourrait de mère
teresa d'afrique du sud mandela dans un
compagnonnage universel eh bien on fera
résonner le champion du monde dans une
aventure qui est relativement original
est en tout cas passionnante et sur ce
patrimoine d'architecturé vernaculaire
l'ambition est de greffer également tout
le patrimoine immatériel les contes les
légendes les danses la cuisine les
vêtements les langues
alors ce projet et vous paraît
impossible mais justement parce qu'il
est impossible on va le faire on va le
faire et c'est la raison pour laquelle
je compte sur vous je vous ai posé la
question tout à l'heure rappelez-vous le
conte oriental je vous ai demandé s'il y
a un mot mais vous auriez aimé
transmettre au prince un mot important
alors pour moi ce serait magnifique hat
un mot latin
ce monde est magnifique ce monde est
beau je bénirai le monde disait rimbaud
avant de mourir dans un hôpital de
marseille au retour de bettini alors
pour vous à défaut d'un mot puisque je
n'ai pas eu de réponse ça pourrait être
un geste une action un engagement une
brique en terre une planche une pierre
de la sueur pour bâtir cette cité de la
paix qui fera date
je pense aux mots de baudelaire gp tri
de la bouille j'en ai fait de l'or ma
grande mon unique ma primitif passion il
vient nous allons pétrir la boue de la
terre-mère pour bâtir lors d'une
fraternité retrouvée et notre lettre de
mission sera ce mot admirable de jean
jaurès jeté du blé aux hommes
vous en ferez des ennemis
donnez leur une cité à construire vous
en ferez des frères alors le moment est
venu
vous connaissez le kaïros le dieu grec
de l'occasion opportune
il a des ailes aux pieds pour rappeler
qu'ils marchent très vite qu'ils courent
est il un coupet sur la tête pour
pouvoir l'attraper quand il passe parce
qu'il ne repasse jamais deux fois
ne le laissez pas passer
le temps est venu
le vent se lève il faut partir disait le
philosophe vladimir jankélévitch alors
ce projet de cité de la paix est le
premier chantier aura lieu l'été
prochain en bretagne dans une ville qui
est des jours dans ma tête mais je ne
vous dirai pas le nom aujourd'hui
simplement je vous demande de retenir
effectivement cette date de l'été 2008
2019 car je compte sur vous pour bâtir
ce chantier et je vous en remercie par
avance
[Applaudissements]